CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
ADKINS BASE BACKER FORTRESS
BRADFORD BY ADAM PROTECTING
TALLY DODD TORONTO EDMUND GLAZER
GONZALES GROVE HERZBERG WESSEL
HURTADO JONES CAMCORDER LAYERED
LLEVA THE MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S
MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A TROUBLED
PAM BORTON TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHITE HUSKY
WINNER WILL. MORE MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON THE
ROAD AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE. WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR OFF AFTER
WHICH ROUTE SHOULD REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR ARTILLERY. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. GRACIOUS GOD AND
GOD OF OUR ANCESTORS AS WE
CELEBRATE PRESIDENTS DAY. WE ASK
YOUR BLESSINGS FOR OUR COUNTRY
FOR ITS GOVERNMENT FOR ITS
LEADERS AND ADVISORS. AND FOR
ALL WHO EXERCISE JUST AND
RIGHTFUL AUTHORITY. TEACH THEM
INSIGHTS FROM YOUR SPIRIT. THAT
THEY MAY ADMINISTER ALL AFFAIRS
OF STATE FAIRLY. PEACE AND
SECURITY JUSTICE AND FREEDOM MY
FOREVER ABIDE IN OUR MIDST.
CREATOR OF ALL BLESS ALL THE
INHABITANTS OF OUR COUNTRY WITH
YOUR SPIRIT. MANY CITIZENS OF
ALL RACES AND CREEDS FORGE A
COMMON BOND IN TRUE HARMONY. TO
BANISH HATRED AND BIGOTRY. AND
TO SAFEGUARD THE IDEALS AND FREE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE DESIRE. MAY
THIS LAND BE AN INFLUENCE FOR
GOOD THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
UNITING ALL PEOPLE IN PEACE AND
FREEDOM. HELPING THEM TO FULFILL
THE VISION OF YOUR PROFIT ISAIAH
. NATION SHALL NOT LIFT UP SWORD
AGAINST NATION NEITHER SHALL THE
EXPERIENCE WAR ANYMORE. FOR THIS
WE PRAY AMEN. SENATOR'S LATEST
GEMMA PLEASE PLACE YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART AS WE HONOR OUR
UNIFORM OVERSEAS MAY THEY BE
PEACEFUL PEACEFUL OUTCOME I
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. READERS WERE READY TO BEGAN
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
WE'LL BE DOING READ. MESSAGE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE TEAM
RIGHT. PORTS OF COMMITTEES WHO
BECAME RED. MOTIONS IN REAL
RESOLUTIONS. ARE THEIR MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS. THERE ARE ENDED UP
EFFORTS READING OF FOR BE DEEMED
. CONSIDERATION OF THE. DAILY
FOR GOVERNOR APPOINTMENT SENATOR
ARE YOU. WHEN YOU EADY.
UNDERSECRETARY YES THAT'S RIGHT
YEAH. YEAH MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DEBORAH COCHRAN
AS CHIEF OF THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PRIOR TO THIS POSITION SHE WAS
SERVING AS EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS WHERE
SHE HELD VARIOUS ROLES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY NINTH ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE IN ONE. MOMENT
ALAN. HI I. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
. BASED FIVE FIVE BACKER. HI
FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM I
PROTESTING MY FAMILY I DON.
THERON FIVE EGGMAN I LASER.
SEVEN DOLLARS I GROVE HI I
PURCHASED BERG. WHEN. HI HER
TADO. JOHN I CAN'T. FIVE LAYER.
LLEVA. HI THE MOANS. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT HI A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FOURTEEN TINA. I
RALPH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. TURN
HI I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI. I
WINNER WELL HI I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS.
ATKINS PORCHES YES I. JOHN THE
LATER. BECAUSE FROM HERTZ BERG.
HER TADO. WHERE MANY. MAN I
SKINNER I WINNER. FIVE THIRTY
THREE NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED AND ACCEPT THIS FALL
ITEM TO SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FILA ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR RULES ON CREDIT CREATION
UP AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AIR
TO THIS ROLE HE WAS SERVING AS
DEPUTY HEALTH OFFICER FOR CONTRA
COSTA HEALTH SERVICES. HAS ALSO
COCHAIR OF THE HEALTH EQUITY
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY NINTH FIVE ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. WELCOME SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FALLING TO.
ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
. EIGHT FIVE I BACKER. HI FOR
JUST FIVE I BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY I DON
. TORONTO I LASER. GONZALEZ I
GROSS HI HEARD SPURRED WHAT. HI
TADO. JONES I CANNOT. I LAYERED
LABOUR I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN HI A CELLO I CAN. HI
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. I
REVIEW I SCANNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER HI WHITE HOUSE V. I.
WINNER. WELL I. FIVE THIRTY
THREE NOTES ZERO THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR IS A LITTLE TOO
NOISY THIS MORNING SHOW. BACKS
UP ITS FALL ITEM THREE. SENATOR
BATES. THE SURVEY TO RATE YES
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DENISE TO GUARD EIGHT AND
ROBINSON KEYS TO THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD MARKET LOAF
WHERE DOES TO THE MAP MINING AND
GEOLOGY BOARD AND TOMMY RANDALL
TO THE OFF HIGHWAY MOTOR VEHICLE
RECREATION COMMISSION THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED ON A
FIVE ZERO VOTE BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
NINTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. THE CARD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FARM THREE NO I.
ALAN AND I ARE CHILE. I HAD TENS
BAIT HI I. BECKER. I HI BRADFORD
I HAVE A DAUGHTER LIFE FOR
TESTING I DALLY I DON. THEY'RE
ALSO I AGREE IN I LASER.
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HEARD SPURRED
WHAT I HI HER TADO. JONES HI I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED FLAVOR. HI
THE MON I WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN
. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TROUBLE
HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO. HI
BROUGHT I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN HI NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. WELL I. FIVE THIRTY
THREE NOS ZERO. THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED ON. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE ANY
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THE START.
CORRECT RIGHT HERE AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT AT TEN
O'CLOCK BUDGETS OF THREE WILL
MEET IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
MEMBERS ARE A TEN O'CLOCK BUT
IT'S- THREE WILL MEET IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OLD THREE. NOW
ANNOUNCEMENT. OCT I GET IT AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S MEMBERS IS THE
LAST DAY TO INTRODUCE BILLS THE
SENATE DOES WILL BE OPEN UNTIL
FIVE O'CLOCK TODAY FOUR
INTRODUCTION OF BILLS SO AGAIN
TODAY UP UNTIL FIVE O'CLOCK WE
CAN INTRODUCE BILLS. NOW MEMBERS
WERE RETURNING BACK TO PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR JONES
REPAIR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR I WOULD ASK MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING BILLING JANICE
JONES MY PARENTS TODAY ON THEIR
FIFTY FIFTH WEDDING ANNIVERSARY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GRADUATIONS
SENATOR LAMAR. I WOULD ON BEHALF
OF OUR HOUSE LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE TWO PEOPLE- ONE
WHOSE BIRTHDAY IS TODAY THE
GREAT SENATOR FROM FREMONT
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE A ANOTHER BIRTHDAY TOMORROW
THIS CALL THESE TOMORROW SO
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO THE BOTH OF
YOU ON BEHALF OF OUR HOUSE. WE
HAVE THE SENATE WOULD LIKE TO
WISH BOTH SENATORS OR COLLEGE
YOU KNOW WHAT AND WHERE A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. SENATOR NELSON.
THAT'S PRESENT ON THE CONDITION
THE FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
PASSED ON THE CONDITION THE FILE
. I HAVE GOT TO AND A MOVED TO
COMMENT ON THE ACTIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
TRUSTEES YESTERDAY. IN THE
ARROGANT MANNER IN WHICH THEY
RELIEVE CHANCELLOR JOE CASTRO.
OF HIS RESPONSIBILITIES. THE
DELEGATION AND ACCUSATIONS. THE
PRESIDENT CASTRO WAS NEVER
ALLOWED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REFUTE. WHATEVER'S AT HIS OWN
SIDE OF THE STORY. AND THE
TRUSTEES DID NOT ALLOW THAT
YESTERDAY EITHER. IN FACT IN THE
PROCESS THAT THEY HAVE HAD
SUGGESTED TO HIM. THEY DEVIATED
FROM. I WOULD ARGUE PURPOSELY.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANY INQUIRY. THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE AN INVESTIGATION. THE
SITUATION. THE BOARD PROCEEDED
THE INVESTIGATION. PROCEEDED.
BASED ON ALLEGATIONS. I BELIEVE
THAT THERE WERE FALSE ONES. AND
I'VE KNOWN THE MAN FOR DECADES.
HE CAME UP THROUGH THE RANKS THE
CSU. BECAME A KIND OF A
BREAKTHROUGH PIONEER WHERE THE
CSU FOR YEARS WAS TRYING TO FIND
ITS PRESIDENTS AND- NATIONWIDE
SEARCHES. INSTEAD OF LOOKING
WITHIN AND LIFTING UP THEIR OWN. JOE CASTRO IS ONE OF THE FIRST
. LUCIEN CAME UP THROUGH THE
RANKS. WHAT MESSAGE IS THAT
TRUSTEES. TO THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
FOR CSU. THE MESSAGES YOUR
BACKUP. YOU'LL DO WHATEVER YOU
DEEM POLITICALLY CORRECT INNER
REGULARLY SO AND TRY TO INSULATE
YOURSELF FROM AN INNING IN FOUR
IS A CRITICISM OF YOU. WELL
TRUSTEES I AM ENQUIRING ABOUT.
I'M GOING TO SUBMIT A REQUEST.
FOR INFORMATION. ABOUT SOME OF
YOUR INTERNAL PROCEDURES. AND
COMMUNICATIONS THAT CIRCULATED
RIGHT BEFORE THE SECTION OF
YESTERDAY BETWEEN THE TRUSTEES
EACH OTHER AND OTHER PARTIES.
TRULY IT'S A DISGRACE. THIS IS
AN OUTRAGE. AND THEY'VE TRIED TO
DESTROY THE CAREER. A LIFETIME
OF SERVICE TO OUR STUDENTS. JOE
CASTRO. I RESENT THAT THE CAST
OF UNFAVORABLE LIGHT THE ENTIRE
CSU SYSTEM. AND I HOPE THE
LEADERSHIP IN THE AREA. THAT
INCLUDES THE UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENT. INDIRECT RYAN FILE.
LET THEIR CONCERNS BE KNOWN AS A
SIGN. MAYBE THESE TRUSTEES WILL
GET IT. OR MAYBE THEY'LL
GRACIOUSLY HELPED US ALL BY
LEAVING OFFICE. IN OUR BORDERS
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. THIS PRESIDENT
TO CONDITION THE FILE PLEASE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO
HAMMER US AT A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT POINTS I WON'T BELABOR
THEM FURTHER. I JUST THINK IT'S
A MATTER OF DUE PROCESS. THAT
ALL OF US SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW THIS MATTER WAS
HANDLED AND WHAT I MEAN BY DUE
PROCESS. IS THAT IF SOMEBODY IS
ACCUSED OF MISHANDLING OF
MATTERS. IN THERE ARE ENTITIES
INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS
ESPECIALLY INSTITUTION TEAM THIS
THIS ISSUE SYSTEM. THAT
INDIVIDUAL ON BE AFFORDED A
CERTAIN PRESUMPTIONS UNTIL AN
INVESTIGATION YIELDS A RESULT.
WHAT I'M SEEING RIGHT NOW IS A
PRESUMPTION OF GUILT WITHOUT
HAVING ALREADY CONDUCTED AN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION. NO I'M
NOT GOING TO SAY WHETHER OR NOT
THE INDIVIDUAL SHOULD HAVE
MERITED DISMISSAL AT SOME POINT
IN TIME. OR WHETHER HE SHOULD
HAVE STAYED BECAUSE HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN- ARE FOUND TO HAVE.
ACTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
PROCEDURES AND EXPECTATIONS. BUT
I WOULD EXPECT AN INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER LEARNING BEING LED BY A
BOARD OF TRUSTEES WOULD HAVE
ALTERED THE NOTION. OF DUE
PROCESS. AND IF THAT WASN'T
AFFORDED THAT I THINK WE ARE
BEING HYPOCRITICAL OF WHAT WE
EXPECT OUR STUDENTS TO LEARN IN
OUR SYSTEM. ALL IN MY COMMENTS
HERE FOLKS. ONCE AGAIN IT'S NOT
WHETHER OR NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
MERITED A REPRIMAND TO DISMISSAL
OR AN ACQUITTAL. BUT I GUARANTEE
THAT. OUTCOME THAT OCCURRED WITH
THAT FORMER FRESNO STATE
EMPLOYEE. HOW DO WOMEN SIGNED
OFF BY OTHER INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
THE CSU SYSTEM. SO IT KIND OF
BEGS THE QUESTION IF THERE WERE
INTERNAL PROCESSES THE PLAY THAT
HAD TO HAVE BEEN GREEN LIGHTED
BY INDIVIDUALS ON THE BOARD OR
WITHIN STAFF. IT FURTHER BEGS
THE POINT THAT INDIVIDUAL SHOULD
BE AFFORDED DUE PROCESS AND FROM
WHAT I CAN TELL THAT DID NOT
OCCUR HERE. JENNER COVER YOUR-
CAREER FOR WHAT PURPOSE- OUR
MEMBERS WERE BACK TO THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. GENERAL
AMONG. THE COMPANY BECAUSE MINE
IS. MARK IS AVAILABLE ON THIS
TOPIC. OKAY SO MEMBERS OF THE
SORRY TO CHANGE THE TOPIC BUT I
DID WANT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT-
WE HAD ANOTHER BIRTHDAY AS
SENATOR MENENDEZ WAS BIRTHDAY
WAS YESTERDAY- AND SO WE ALSO
WANT TO WISH HER A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AND SHE JUST STEPPED
OUTSIDE BUT SHE'S HERE SOMEWHERE
SO HAPPY BIRTHDAY ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WORD
WHICH SENATOR MELINDA IS. A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. MEMBERS IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR BATES. THE DESK CLERK.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
FIVE PM AT WHICH TIME THE
INTERNET MOTION WILL BE PLACED
WE WILL RECONVENE TUESDAY AT TWO
PM AND EVERYONE HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND. MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL FIVE PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WILL
RECONVENE ON TUESDAY AT TWO PM.
AND YOUR YOUR HOLIDAY WEEK AND.